[Applause]
so treatises yes you're not the sister
are you know probably look
brother-in-law
now tonight is all about good food made
fast yeah we're not started cooking I
know we're ready Jane and cut but that
side Wendy Alice on this side yes you're
right Wendy
yes chef commend you what is it the menu
tonight chef is where I start we've got
fresh tuna we've
holy [ __ ] I'm now starting to [ __ ]
myself
you're soaking like a baby what's going
on and I'm getting slightly nervous okay
it's a seared tuna salad nicoise okay
that was a [ __ ] start let's do the first
table together time six minutes for the
eggs right listen
the only thing we're cooking is the
chooser at the last minute and the eggs
three or four potatoes
each yes handful of beans yes pitted
olives
I sure lot rings yes cherry tomatoes yes
yes yes well they called anchovies
anchovies Felix good dress that that's
done olive oil in the pan nice and hot
rocks in literary one minute each side
yeah turn bring the heat back up to the
pan we're gonna go
[Music]
Oh sliced kettle I don't want it ripped
look see it beautiful pink in the center
eggs out please and then from there open
Oh where's the ACE eggs now I'm sorry
but there's nothing difficult there is
there let's go go
good girl careful careful [ __ ] drizzle
inside there it is fit for a king dick
right you pay for that lovely go on
Ivana transfer guide is Wendy Allison
Jane and Cuthbert but as you can see by
my four feet I really do love food
now go abroad how will it taste what
they cook never don't like it at least
I've tried it but I do love cooking
since I've been the age of eight I've
been cooking some people find cooking or
I've got a go and cook dinner but when I
get up of lawn you know I wonder what am
I gonna cook for that evening meal well
my favorite is I like doing fish and
chips I'll use a nice point a lager any
better family's very important to us
there's so many of us and you don't need
anyone else if you've got family in your
clothes I think maybe Addison Wendy
there's always enjoyed cookies and some
difficult sparks in the kitchen of
golden like both love about the f-word
I'm the most aggressive I'll definitely
a.m. I'll know that but it's probably
some gum from each other Oliver I
believe we are going to be the best
brigade Golding there's ever had here I
have mr. Ramsay we're on yeah to cover
several 9t settings while to roast
chicken to apple and pear right cut but
it's two tuna salads too to understand
one egg for two portions you've got four
[ __ ] eggs in there sorry chef one egg
two portions Oneg - lets go big man so
we want to shake one washes
I'll catch it sorry shape right listen
yes no one should be dressed in the
summer it should be a bit cheese already
who's doing the salads this is another
fine mess I got myself into calculus yes
sorry about that it's nice and pink all
the grass on my back garden so I've
decided to send them up the property
ladder right no my gorgeous lamb Sharla
and Gavin are now 9 weeks old putting on
two kilos a week my flock is eating me
out of house and home
chief early wedding still suggested by
fine new pasture a special help keep
their mothers producing rich milk and
good grazing will give Shawn and Gavin
great flavor
John Yvonne's got astroturf and you've
got no grass left is that right Dan I
said no action you've really seriously
pulled me other [ __ ] I can assure you
thank you
see in two weeks today is moving day but
moving livestock is not my bag luckily
hewers volunteer to help hopefully he
also knows how to dismantle a sheep Hut
I really hate DIY you're not telling me
who where they're going Gordon she has
an amazing she is it yes amazing garden
yeah I think got a decent bit of grass
on it
yes it's got long grass we need to spend
straw in the trailer to make the Sheep
comfortable during the journey yes being
a nice place to be it also helps you to
feel at home how easy is that it's
common practice for farmers like you to
move sheep from pasture to pasture just
get on the trainer will follow but not
so usual in South West London anymore
can't believe how good they were getting
in there yeah they'll be quite comfy
back there I'll find out later or Hugh
makes of their new home
[Music]
I loved it I door tuner anyway the tuna
was cooked superbly it was a little bit
pink and the eggs were very flavorsome
they were lovely that the tuna was well
cooked if a little bit cold all in all I
enjoyed it
results JB can we go so for starters
37 hours listen keep it going you are
now in the lead yes okay
don't [ __ ] it up you got 37 out of 50
okay
next on the menu the foodie gobshite
gives me another mouthful can't believe
I'm 40 years of age and Janice reporters
line feeding me just look at it as kinky
sex oh my god
the brigade serves up a delicious main
course of chicken in a Morel sauce with
seasonal asparagus and eccentric talent
scout David gest helps me my search for
a new female cook we've found the vagina
cup we can find him at Barney
welcome back to the F word now time for
the main course no stop stop stop that
dead bird
pan-fried chicken breast with morel
sauce chicken is the nation's favorite
meat we've roasted it
we stir-fried it we've carried it this
is a new dimension so with a wonderful
rich morel sauce just before it goes in
the pan get your cloth there just Pat it
dry that gets rid of any excess moisture
therefore when it goes in the pan it
doesn't spit at you
seasoned skin side down into the pan
garlic
time knob of butter in
straight into the other eight to ten
minutes 180 degrees Morel sauce and the
most important thing about these driver
Al's is you just add boiling water it
rehydrates the mushroom then there's an
added bonus you've got your own mushroom
stock drain off pan mushroom we into the
pan shallots
Yanik
time
especially wine wine so why start to
sweeten it up mushroom stock
reduce
crane
bring out to the ball and literally just
took it one minute
the secret now is to pass the sauce
through the sieve get a ladle and just
push a wonderful color not too thick and
full of flavor asparagus
there is season and it's British cut off
the bottom part of the spear that's the
woody part though throw it went great
for stocks and great for soups first
when we cook them from Raw on a griddle
pan olive oil
[Applause]
spectrum or our mushrooms just cut them
into halves so to the mushroom hot olive
oil fresh thyme and finish at the very
end with a touch of butter
start from the top and just slice in
half I fresh morel mushrooms sauce over
goodbye stir-fry goodbye roast chicken
no more curries bass which is at his
best
pan fried chicken with a morel sauce
done yes don't keep on washing them in a
way that they get too broken up be very
careful
mushu's nice hot fan you do not bowl
with mushrooms you so do the mushrooms
yes let's go the sauce is much Wendy so
get it too dark
[Music]
yes slicing the chicken right yes yes
okay
look on the hot plate waiting what I'm
trying to say first the chicken gets
sliced last yes days aren't cooked
mushrooms are out of the pan and now you
want to argue so I'm just trying to get
you organized stop cycle the chicken for
five minutes and help get the food in
the [ __ ] ball watch out here is the
biggest gob in the food world pressed
foie gras marinated in white bull foie
gras marinated in Pinot Noir caramel off
this menu honey and saw a roasted quail
with foie gras and spiced pear chutney
well if you ask me Gordon is bloody
obsessed with foie gras if you go
through the menus of his restaurants
photograph features of nearly every one
foie gras is a foodies delight it has a
unique buttery taste and texture that
makes it often irresistible but the
trouble is the way that the French make
it is by force-feeding ducks and geese
holding their beaks open and shoving
down a lot of food and quite frankly
that's a bit repulsive isn't it
well I think the French think that foie
gras is a French food nobody else can
produce it and they own the copyright on
it you like but that French monopoly is
now being challenged by a so called
ethical foie gras from Spain I want to
know if the French and Spanish products
can even compare if they can I'm going
to change Gordon to change his mind and
his menus to get to the bottom of all
this who [ __ ] about for our graph
decided to come to the heart of rural
France to the door dine and pay my first
visit ever to a foie gras farm for gras
it's true L know it's not cross look at
this log they're not rushing so that
makes me think they don't really want
I'm told the birds on this farm received
six kilos of grain a day the actual
business of putting the to desert road
that I find quite hard to look at French
farmers insist that only force-feeding
can create the taste and texture what
seems like a cruel way of producing a
delicacy is simply a continuation of a
centuries-old tradition
[Music]
I know the most intelligent animals but
there must have a little brain until I
really like this I mean the pluses about
a massive dinner
the downside is their life's good away
and in a few days time animal and
probably the last night Mary's gonna
have his Janet Street Paul's are holding
him after two to three weeks of force
feeding the liver is at its most
engorged and the duck is slaughtered the
liver is ten times bigger than normal
and it's this unnatural amount of fat
that creates the distinctive taste now
I'm having second thoughts I wasn't very
happy seeing out the geese were fed just
give me a lot to think about
I'm probably I'm gonna have nightmares
now that's battle I won't be eating it
anymore
[Music]
now what's really pissed the French off
is the Spanish producers of won the
prestigious medal for innovation at the
Paris international food salon and
they're not happy now it's time to put
this Spanish product to the test if I'm
to have any hope of changing Gordon's
mind I've got to find him an alternative
that rivals the taste of the French I
mean why would all know say we don't
need of a do you know him - he thinks
that also case where are they
farmer Eduardo explains that if we kneel
down the geese will come freely to us
[Music]
each year the geese binge eat local
acorns and olives to prepare for their
migration return again totally Berta
even the Opera very song felices so what
this is like a five-star hotel luxury
hotel for gays but unlike most hotels
the best fed guests get slaughtered how
do you know when the liver is ready when
they are ready to be cold or a madman
Taekwondo Bobby needle and Friel
is your hemp it's an AK American uniform
a saint non-stop sounds a lot of people
I know Eduardo seeing the birds in their
natural environment was a refreshing
sight but I couldn't help wondering
would their livers be as stuffed with
fat as their ethical credentials
but most crucially with the Spanish
tastes as good as the French delicious
why not well this product has got all
the taste a none of the cruelty toast
bloody marvelous
this is food that you can eat with a
clear conscience so I'm going to go back
home I'm a bloody gonna force-feed it to
pee right
why oh why because you're shouting so
much more than love can we do a J okay
if you can't tell the difference between
the Icicle Quadra and the horrible jube
down your gob wah grah okay that you
serve yes the ethical far ground trust
me if I cannot tell the difference I
will serve it in my ration okay okay off
we go first one okay they can't cry
I'll stop them kinky for God's sake you
swatted it yang oh my god okay no please
can't believe I'm 40 years of age and
Janice reporters line feeding me yeah
thank you just look at it as kinky sex
oh my god first one was very smooth it
sort of you know it sort of lined the
roof of my mouth the second one was a
lot rougher but didn't have the impact
of the richness of a fog arm which one
would you like to serve in your
definitely the first one smooth oh yeah
yeah the second one is the ethical one
which goes just go don't go doesn't mind
listen excuse me that confirms that my
palate ten times better than yours JD
help Janet back to her wheelchair please
let's go 30 seconds guys I'm sorry but
this is one hour and 20 minutes
I've got enough potatoes here for two
part of this everyone just disappeared
but it gets to the exciting part
no one's here is it's okay chef right
that one's got no sauce that one's got
sauce that wasn't on the side I'm not
gonna argue just get some sauce on there
okay dirty plates fuckles next two
nights
I can't ask these people to pay you've
got to serve them but they're not
expecting to pay one hour 25 minutes
that did not need to be that hard
you're a family there's nothing
close-knit and what you've just done now
for the dessert you have to work as a
team he was slicing yes chicken and
Wendy was oblivious that you're doing it
I don't what I said to you from now oh
did I get Shep I said chef not blaming
Wendy but she's a [ __ ] I'll do the side
get the plights out or deed did I did on
the flesh I did not say get the blood
sale it's not about blame is about
working together self
for the desert we have to work together
David good to see my man how is Neil be
well I'm very good guys Lane's good
evening
how's the main course excellent this was
good you enjoyed it yes yeah really good
the chicken was nice the mushrooms nice
yeah would you pay for that I didn't you
invited me as your guest you can afford
12 pounds can't you powerful star to
know you sir
you would pay 12 pounds for that good I
have a gift for you
already yes that's right Connie my
housekeeper vagina Cosima right is a
surreal she's real she wants you to know
she is writing her own cookbook the
vagina Cosima cookbook and she has a
very special semen cake very salty but
you're gonna get it she's sitting female
this is from Regina cut Cup links a
blind man made them for her but there's
a V for vagina Kerr yeah you're a very
generous man honey yes now you married
Liza yes did you ever cook from know she
once cooked for me she used a lot of
wine were you I just was joking lawyers
the right amendment
she didn't use wine she used beer and
she used vodka okay did you ever argue
over food
no because we both like the same foods
and she would always steal from my plate
not steal from her plate yes we she she
had a great appetite now you've got an
eye for talent you're hearing less so
I've been searching to find a new
talented female cook I need your help
now to get the word out there spread the
word to the nation right and I think
this is gonna be right up your street I
want you to get it out on the streets
find me I love it okay I will yes please
yeah we're done grease I found the
vagina kill we can find him of Bonnie
thank you
as when a pleasure
don't forget that t-shirt yes I will
thank you what the [ __ ] is he on
now I really enjoy guys
the potatoes were about and about dente
is nice vegetable
okay we were slow what a shape so let's
find out how many customers out of 50
paid for the main
30 customers pay for the main course 30
20 didn't
for what reason what they say so
obviously too long too long again II
we're all potatoes in a bit bland yeah
but we didn't know potatoes on the move
let's get 50 out of 50 yes paying for
the dessert yes next on the menu lures
Alex James takes meal and the recipe
challenge because it's [ __ ]
disgusting if the company tits up when
desserts get burnt oh yeah if you look I
put me in the [ __ ] beam on this one
and I become the deer hunter
now
walkabout deaf work now time for me to
be Alex James in the recipe challenge
ready ready right what am i doing
what are you doing Alex I'm doing breast
of lamb roast of lamb rolled and stuffed
up with mushrooms baked it in hey on a
bed of spinach with some bakes a lot
nothing fancy you are quite a secret
little foodie Arnie when you live in the
country kind of life does tend to
revolve around food really I mean it
your take all day making uh making
dinner
Rumour Has that you're turning is a bit
of a sort of Shoop only witnessed oh yes
this sort of the trout farm phase of
this sort of rock star trajectories as
inevitable as the sort of model chasing
Busey phase you know so alex is doing a
stuff west of land long we'll do a set
of land stuff with wild mushrooms sage
Liberty mint and some mascarpone cheese
bound together with some spinach and
alex is using hey I'm not because it's
[ __ ] disgusting why hey it's nice it
gives it a night it does give it a nice
flavor I'm gonna give it a bit of a
scorch so you get like caramelized Hey
so you have a bit sweeter yes Lee fast
I'm go to the city speed no go the
country speeds this year it's pretty
hard for me to imagine that you're a
rock star
now you're this laid-back country month
when you cease all that hair Alex yeah
man coming through one ECU looking
through one eye yeah I get this right is
flash so you got mushrooms in there yeah
just giving it a little roll nice huh
it's quite well trim please actually
yeah there you go try that industry yeah
if I can
that's the tricky bit excellent very
chef-y that you know that okay
okay after so many years as a highly
successful band yeah and a rock and roll
lifestyle to go with it don't you miss
it I kind of I wouldn't like to think
they'd never be another blow record but
I don't I don't sort of yearn for it now
I think it's you know it's it's a hard
thing just sort of leave behind of
course but I think it's you know it's
been good that there's not been sort of
a blur record for a while because we all
kind of needed to learn how to sort of
be be grownups yeah that's looks all
right yeah I'll tell you what from a
from a chefs point of view it looks like
it's tied nice and tightly and
importantly now you stuff that nothing's
leaking out this is very the guy who
sold my pigs I showed him this hand he
said that's too good holy [ __ ] you're
serious
so what we do with a how you've wet it
Alex wet it and then give it a bit of I
haven't tried this before
now you're gonna set fire to it you're
like a countryside after this I can't
believe you setting fire to the hey Alex
it looks like a large birds nest yes
innit so mushrooms are in there spillage
is in there we're just gonna season it
now with some lightly grated nutmeg salt
pepper some a tablespoon of mascarpone
cheese and bind all those mushrooms and
the eggs together and stuff that inside
the saddle of lamb Alex you wrap the
breast in hey you don't have to include
Phil now you wrapped it in tinfoil
what's next carpet what are you doing
look at that can't argue with that late
that's that's posh sounds good for mine
stays on top little Phil it's on top and
then just wrap nice and tightly over
hoping all that stays in there so the
idea that haze to what perfume it yeah
just give it gives it a bit of flavor
you know and then it keeps it quite
moist as well
so then you just give a little fry at
the end oh so you're crisping yours now
I mean Chris it I've got a really nice
and crisp on the outside season it and
once it's all sealed I can put it on the
oven it'd be very hard to get this color
on the oven spread away you're ready in
the oven 30 minutes each yeah Oh top
shelf just in there like that yeah okay
good yeah 30 minutes but now I want to
talk to you about your unusual sort of
calcium intake you will yes drank your
wife's breast milk I did what's all that
about
well she had twins and she's been in
hospital for like three months with
their mother she got out I might see the
Foo Fighters had a few beers right their
milk was condemned so I didn't want to
throw it away it's got to be good for us
it's got less fat more protein it's got
to be better for you than cow's milk I
mean it's this human though I'm you
looking at me now as if you just put it
in your [ __ ] new cheese recipe have
you made cheese with it yet people have
tried but it won't coagulate but we
could do a pretty good cappuccino yeah
for it with bris milk rock and roll
now time to see if the companies know
their apples and pears yes
[Music]
generalize apples and pears a perfect
dessert this time of year this is a
brave one Apple nice and crisp full of
juice
hardly any acidity this is a commis pair
now quite robust quite dense in the
center but the most amazing flavor very
very sweet right when we Carol eyes free
you've got to call the center down in
twist
nice thin slices as you feel the secret
behind roasting apples and pears and
making sure that they're not too ripe if
they're slightly too right then the
whole thing disintegrates and the pants
look at that smells amazing
now we will form a really nice caramel
but we're gonna season this can with
black pepper star nice and close and
that gives a really nice spice flavor
when you caramelize mouth with an pears
and sugar get it really nice and even
therefore the caramel starts cooking
evenly but isn't burning the corners but
so that stops it from separating and
splitting
spice cinnamon stick pears and apples in
but the fat side down now that I'm happy
with that color I'm gonna add my
Calvados and it sort of thing richest
the Kerala Onyx pieces
[Music]
then finish with apple juice it just
sort of liquefied the caramel and just
takes the heaviness out of it bring that
to the boil and just coat the apples in
pairs and let it blaze over and serve
smells amazing
you know just finish that with some ice
cream on caramelized apples and pears
with ice cream
done we serve the madeleine because it's
a really nice it compliment my skin is
like a nice little sort of bait sponge
but you've tasted the perfect Madeleine
yes
trust me never ever forget 50 like that
and they're paid for it yes all the pace
I'm doing the pace the pace first apple
juice last wash your fingers put it back
got the bottle away from the flame
you'll go up in a [ __ ] Oh let's go we
send out please
don't toss it with Calvin off from there
you'll [ __ ] set yourself on fire do
these go
careful careful you gonna really hurt
yourself yeah great careful now yeah
hopefully my I'm gonna change it was
laughing a [ __ ] a let me show
something oh [ __ ] there you go
yeah let's just come back so right now
right now
you all make myself look [ __ ] stupid
okay so hey no no no chef Mele there
because I didn't put the other twice
listen don't sir black Madeline's end
the story okay chef that was a mishap
all the others if you look I put me in
the [ __ ] bin at least one sorry I'm
back said I missed one and if we have a
Mac you mean this bone is in the feed or
Fulham in there I'm at least one I just
sent it back you not apologizing because
let's go up because I thought I've got a
little off that's the strength of your
apology hello hey sorry chef oh I'm
sorry shake like these ones are firm
there's weird [ __ ] does that really
broke one officer tried to backhand side
effect right they are they shake turn
the tray out alright hey laughing I've
got some maintenance you've got another
try left in there
while deer are the most loved and
respected of game their beautiful
majestic creatures whilst their meat is
widely regarded as the most regal of
delicacies now I've been given the
chance to hunt and kill a deer myself
I'm in the middle of forest here in
Thetford right in the heart of Norfolk
I've never shot a deer I've never been
stalking before and I cannot wait I've
always wanted to stalk wild deer
it's one of the ultimate standoffs
between man and beast a centuries-old
tradition with a huge payoff a chance to
eat some of the finest game in the world
[Music]
hi sir Highgarden welcome to that expert
deer hunter Alan McCormick is going to
show me the ropes
it doesn't sound easy and what you're
looking at doing is lining up on the
back of the leg right and it's a third
to half way up and essentially that's
going to go through the vital organs of
the heart and lungs and the deer and
that's a clean that's a clean shot okay
good excellent how exciting so you can
see that nice and steady
three
[Music]
when you're ready stacks can weigh up to
350 kilo almost four times my weight and
it takes great skill to kill a fully
grown deer humanely and of course the
problem is is that if you need that
second shot yeah we need to then sort it
out quickly Chris I only hope I can make
the all-important clean kill when it's
my time to pull the trigger [ __ ] I can't
see any holes there
oh there's one there's two Murray goes
now every one of those shots would have
taken that deer and killed it really
right
you're obviously a driven and
competitive person this isn't a
competition we've got a waiter this is
alright I've said every time it's right
then it's fine sharks on we take off
well done
we'll hunt for real tomorrow in the
meantime Allen's got some fresh venison
liver from a kill first thing this
morning it will make the perfect
hunter's meal what fascinates me with
this particular dish is that the
distillate back in the early days with
sort of treatment of their main meal fry
up some shallots pancetta a bit of wild
garlic and some mushrooms
it's [ __ ] delicious I just leave them
there I'm just gonna do a really nice
sort of crouton for the bacon to sit on
into the olive oil and now for the liver
it sounds like this I feel a little bit
like a Hannibal Lecter nice big thick
slices it's really important when you're
cooking with liver its season the liver
at the very last minute otherwise it
dries out look at the color of that
liver one minute each size pan smoking
almost treat it like you're cooking a
nice piece of Phillips take a towel
piece of Philip and I'll tell you what
it doesn't become any fresher than that
I'm surprised there's no more deer that
rock up that smells amazing now he's
nice that really is nice it's off to bed
early to rise the stalk starts at dawn
we need to be really quiet here okay
sort of a deer at any point anywhere
the planet is talking silence before we
see a deer then take aim and fire but
with a film crew a thick mist and my
inexperience that's easier said than
done after two hours of trudging around
on the ground we still had no luck it
was time to move to a high seat which in
this weather should give us more chance
okay
take as much time as you can need horse
up there the answer hair lovely huh no
no wasn't name take you there you know
your bloody walk yeah what you do when
you're this high up and you need
desperate need for number two oh they
just come out yeah
steady steady steady it's alright when
they may come back again steady
for a clean quick kill add there needs
to be Sidon and standing still come on
little bastard
turn side on no no no so frustrating
damn there is a condition called buck
fever and it's essential when people get
excited of no anticipation and
adrenaline of trying to but like a
runmel exactly any time now finally
after hours talking I had the perfect
clear shot of a beautiful wild deer in
my sights now
wait please stops no but something
didn't feel right you gotta have to do a
short lane instead of pulling the
trigger I took my finger off it
that was really frustrating after all
those hours spent stalking the deer and
then the chase is exciting there's no
choice about that that's very sort of
boyish but it's really weird when you
get it in your sight and you think gosh
I pull that trigger or not I don't know
maybe I'm becoming a vegetarian
[Music]
next on the menu Alex James tries to
persuade me breast is best I really like
it Alex shoes itchin to know who owns my
new pasture I feel like I'm on through
the keyhole Gordon I can't imagine who
lives here someone with a bit more taste
Lindy again that's Lucifer are you such
a [ __ ] and EastEnders find out if
they've done well enough to come back
and cook in my Western restaurant
results of the desserts out of 50 dinars
walking back the f-word now time for the
results or the recipe challenge times
played up nervous always a little bit
less in the case nothing with it I'm
gonna do a little bit of spinach and
shallots
they smell this hey man it smells like a
[ __ ] pigsty it smells very sweaty it
smells good to me
I think getting a fingers with your
fingers you know yes yes
[Music]
very good flavor coming through
mushrooms lovely that for me is
absolutely sublime well you put me to
the test I'm gonna put you to the test
now okay I want to see if you can taste
one of my very special cappuccinos yeah
let's get rid yeah can you froth breast
milk yeah it [ __ ] lassalle's about how
fresh the milk is that's how well it for
us right okay I can't believe you never
tasted it before
no I'm missing you know that in
California that the ladies are all
having it after their Pilates no I asked
you
breastmilk cappuccino on your cornflakes
all over the place
[Music]
it's sweet it's really sweet in there
but now I really like it
Alex we hear some more and if you have
started a new [ __ ] Craig's it's all
your fault you know that okay right
ready for results
well I wouldn't happy with that at all
[ __ ] breast meat cappuccino Alex okay
if I can use because yeah ones rolled
and wrapped in hey I'm up with a
beautiful salad of lamb don't [ __ ]
around now okay so on this obvious
occasion you're doing up yes yes no well
tell me thank you buddy
ah good luck with the Christmas single
to me do me a favor
yes [ __ ] up out my kitchen go back to
that cheese Thanks
cheers mate yeah
[Music]
today she was helping me transfer my
lambs to pastures new we arrived at my
sheeps Chambery new home while the owner
is still at work I was hoping for
slightly more acreage I'll admit it but
look at the length of this what I like
you know that's good grass well don't
waste it make you eat it I do not want
to look stupid in front of madam you
know that hang on you've got it on the
hammer you need to be able to see
daylight you can see daylight now I feel
like I'm on through the keyhole I can't
imagine who lives here someone with a
bit more taste than you intensive off
are you such a [ __ ] well she has a
creative eye I think should be pretty
much impressed with the way of what they
sit together a couple is familiar little
Palace will help my sheep adjust the new
environment and give them a shelter
place out of the rain good to see you
you've been building [ __ ] you've been
the mystery guest all afternoon I didn't
leave this garden I was in I did say it
was a woman of fast and taste oh I'm so
glad you recognized
[Music]
I'm liking this we do this do I need to
read them do you eat them did you eat
them in yoga when I come home at night
sometimes and to get them out I come by
come by come by it's a bit of a worse
thing we've made my Shepard cry itself
so you do know okay go on
so come by come by come by anyway
they're gonna be really really looks
after here they can have a lovely time I
do think that happy meat tastes better
I've seen bread any problems I'm only 5
minutes down the road I hope that shed
stays up if it doesn't ha the dessert
was really delicious some of the others
were a little bit undercooked and a
little bit hard to cut into
but the ice cream and the Seuss was
really really delicious and I would
definitely pay for the dessert the pears
in the Apple were really really quite
raw really hard to buy couldn't even get
your fork through I scraped my plate
clean the whole thing was really
delicious really complemented each other
really well they're really tasty get
into the meal okay let's go
ladies please here we go let's go let's
go let's go
results of the desserts how do you think
you done chambers a bit more teamwork
I'm the dessert than we did on the mine
so 37 out of 50 for starters 30 out of
54 9 out of 50 dinars yes
twenty-nine are happy to pay for it oh
that's a grand total of 96 out of 150 if
you worked harder as a team and spent
less time shouting you could have done a
lot better why are you so gobby i was
trying to be the leader yes yes right I
there's any one [ __ ] leader here